alors la forme il est signé là tu te
tombent sous le charme sous le charme
danis ouais donc après bon c'est qu'il
va leur tromperie et compagnie parce que
tes fautes parce que j'étais veuf quand
même avant de passer à l'émission ouais
et j'ai pas vu toujours le soleil
briller ou sav ouais j'ai levé ma fille
elle avait dix ans à sa maman cas est
décédé charlene aujourd'hui nos veines
s'est t elle à 27 ans elle a déjà huit
ans de boulot c'est fou ça quand même
assez des métiers je suis fier de ma
fille autre garantie speed dating
oui mais tu es le
formidable de te rencontrer quoi
mon souhait maintenant c'est de trouver
une femme déjà ça ne fait pas peur de
marcher dans la boue auprès du tout
niveau cuisine alors lâchez pas bien
j'aime bien façonné oui j'aime beaucoup
cuisinière si vraiment à 3 heures du
matin j'aurais besoin d'un petit coup de
main est ce que ça te gêne ray de venir
avec moi a pas du tout béton faire un
bel âge là j'en suis partant mais c'est
partant à huy et bah allez on va je vais
t'offrir une petite fleur merci c'est
gentil puis j'espère va venir à la ferme
voir comment ça se passe l'honneur est à
l'heure
[Applaudissements]
et tout ça va finir dans un bain news
parce qu'un mariage ben oui j'ai un
mariage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
manque un sketch au téléphone depuis las
hier ses maquis du appelé surprise c'est
vrai oui pour moi vous aimez bien et où
sa
[Applaudissements]
peine comme
d'habitude la malveillants dans cette
émission
je déconne elle veut tourner près tout
il avait invité chez lui tiens je vais
donner mon nom une vache
[Rires]
mariage de mariah qu'on avance on parle
un peu le mariage qui aiment de thierry
rappelez vous ces bons souvenirs c'est
après que c'est partir en cacahuète bwin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oh
on a beau dire cette émission konan sa
marge est toujours mariée ben oui des
heureux ben oui des enfants ben non
parce qu'elle est plus âgée que moi ah
c'est sûr mais
c'est pas le problème ali a déjà une
petite fille oui moi de mon côté frais
compte qu'au report alors il faut croire
en un peu vous êtes vous êtes heureux
oui avec elle ça serait bien oui très
bien c'est quoi le quotidien sauf le
quotidien
on se lève on fait l'amour et l'amour
on aura j'aime beaucoup le petit outil
dans le tiroir
du savon leur série mais je n'arrive à
rouiller mais là c'est comme un sécateur
salut bientôt retraite et ma femme au 6
mai
et mezze la retraite ça va pas non mais
c'est pour ça mais j'ai déjà une
prothèse de hanche alors je suis malade
du diabète droit j'ai remplacé jean reno
ou pour riespach diamètre de france les
vraies c'est vraiment alors mais
j'arrive à faire quand même mieux si
marrant tous les départements encore
l'autre jour j'ai fait un tournoi
jacques hérisset caudéra vieux tracteurs
aux mots sont ceux des c'était moi que
je deviens ce matin sur presque 55 ans
quand même mais je suis ça donne à voir
comme un fondu donc vous ne regardez pas
de talent émission mais ça va tout
changer j'ai trouvé une faille connue
mairie monsieur je connais ce même
palais michaud quand tu fais fort boyard
je connaissais même pas les messieurs et
la notoriété c'est pas difficile à vis
de notoriété il n'ya pas des mauvais
côtés aussi parce que je suis une très
malade des nerfs à l'intérieur et il ya
des gens baissent un peu trop bien alors
des fois hebinger je prends leur mal
logés dans mon vin et j'ai pas besoin de
moi je ne sois pas c'est que je joue en
tout durant
cette vidéo parce que je crois qu'elle
fait tout les bêtisiers de francs du
monde allait racheter par tous vous avez
la chance de faire fort boyard ouais
c'est vrai rythme un courrier vous avez
tout sauf l'arabe mais sinon l'homme
la clé est restée regarde
elle avait juste absolument incroyable
où la tête à qui n'a jamais fait
[Musique]
dans la tanière de clepsydre qui est
quand même relativement qu il faut bien
rire
alors le problème n'oubliez pas c'est
l'incident à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
en plus des histoires de basket
c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
m
tellement sympathique mais c'est comme
ça c'est la vie c'est comme ça mais la
douceur la gentillesse de bourvil c'est
un compliment bourgvilain mêlera corus
est mon héros un bon bah oui oui la
normandie et vous avez vous imaginé au
mont saint michel ou du matin michel
côté oui c'est pas juste à côté de la
mosquée la mer qui monte ça prend aussi
primé de la ferme époque la mer qui
monte des fois
[Applaudissements]
l'outil marche encore oui
l'outil là bas il a l'air plus frais
il a l'air plus frais ah oui mais qu'est
ce que c'est jean michel lamassiaude
gène j'aimerais demander à thierry
comment commence à ce que j'ai vu vous
avez eu un petit accident de la route ya
quelques temps car oui oui oui un petit
coup de trop vous auriez refusé de vous
et de dépistage et comment ça va ça va
la santé à 100% bien accord mais
conduisait 70 ans du rejet j'étais en
manque de sucre alors comme les
diabétiques font déjà un vote car elle
savait moi j'ai du succès toujours j'en
excès de sucre avant elle a tout de
suite j'ai joué deux
mais j'ai fait quatre âmes 68 dans les
yeux ah oui plus présents dans les dents
tout ça et c'est pour ça que tu avais
marre avait d'ailleurs dans télé star ce
que vous avez du diabète oui marché non
non je suis juste très ouverte et
thierry vous vous buvez pas avant de
prendre le volant quand même basé mais
il c'est à dire
on avait bu quelques bières mais mais je
vais vous donner vie vous savez vous
savez que quand on est reconnu un peu
pour la france comme ça donc les pas
tout le monde non mais j'ai eu affaire à
des sortes de personnes moi je n'ai
jamais porté plainte chez ces gens là
mais lui ont fait un rapport quand même
sur monde en ski mais j'ai été tabassé
mais bah ça on n'en parle pas normal moi
j'ai pris gens parlent pas passer ce que
je vous laisse pas non non moi je veux
le bon côté de thierry ça n'a pas chassé
le bon vivre où
des gamins quand même
alors lui regarder jean-michel on s'en
souvient saison 6
non
je vais pas parler retard alors saint
michel c'est pas super de ferme des
vaches est pareil tu peux chercher
l'amour ascona du petit portrait de
michel on a on a en a on à rona non on
n'a pas on n'a pas de mutuelle alors
jamais c'est le voilà moi j'y suis allé
plein de bâches vous avez l'exploitation
vous cherchez une femme finalement ce
régime un petit peu à la fin de cette
aventure vous avez perdu l'exploitation
et vous avait pas de femmes non voila
voila c'est un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé quand même te faire donc c'était
des moments difficiles oui parce que
vous vous êtes pas trouvé de femmes
comme hommes comme thierry dans cette
émission avec eux enfin moi voilà je
cherche je laisse les choses se faire
way you lie speed dating vous avez eu un
coup de coeur pendant l'émission oui une
fille oui j'étais avec une fille mais
bon moi je cherche pas j'ai eu les films
et cherche pas que la presse le dhj
l'amour caché et vous l'avez vécu commun
de temps ça t'es mort caché que j'ai
vécu avec une fille presque deux ans
deux ans d'accord et après ça s'est
arrêté après ça ça va s'arrêter après
j'ai connu une fille donc quitter s'est
dit d'accord dans une voiture assez
triste vernon ferrand ouais donc après
je les aventures voilà et là c'est là
que ça va être mis en en parler aussi
parce qu'il ya des yade et vous ça a été
plus compliqué aujourd'hui pour sortait
la tête de l'eau c'est pour dire aussi
que l'émission n'est pas un truc et
pascal de tout irait pour qui ça s'est
bien passé d'autres moi vous souhaitez
plus compliqué lala l'exploitation ne
marche plus vous n'avez plus d'argent
donc vous avez dû vendre toutes vos
vaches après sa frayeur vous avez
toujours rien voilà c'est même qu'on a
essayé de tourner ensemble voulait pas
retourner devant parce que c'est très
triste on est aujourd'hui vous faites
quoi vous vivez de quoi
ba aujourd'hui j'ai gagné l'auto j'ai
gagné de 230 millions d'euros
[Rires]
manger pendant mes bras 2e
aujourd'hui je travaille pour le groupe
vinci dont le quoi le groupe va ainsi
c'est à dire quoi
pour les trains rapides pour le tgv vous
coûter un tgv non non je suis entretien
et sa mort entretient d'accord voyage
entretien des voies ferrées tout ça n'a
rien changé à acheter une maison à tabac
attendre et loire et j'ai sorti un lit
qui s'appelle d'ailleurs les volets
bleus bah oui alors je dis bien tout
s'est montré après parce que j'ai la
voilà donc pas son âme et volé son bleu
est heureux aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut dire aussi comme ça on dit
tout quand vous avez perdu votre vous le
dites dans les bouquets à tous quand
vous avez tout perdu vous avez lu dans
ta carrière tu suicider voilà est en
fait mais je sais pas que quand dans le
sud est on pense plus rien ça me donne
un salut qu'à une longue route pour
aller suivre et retombe à bout entre
guillemets vous regrettez d'avoir fait
l'émission parce que ça vous avez fait
croire à quelque chose peut-être un
jeune frenchie bonne expérience bon
d'accord par le forfait d'un bol en
placardant quoi donc les bonnes
nouvelles c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
toujours pas trouvé l'amour non mais je
suppose que c'était bien vous veniez
aussi parce que c'est toujours le même
bonjour monsieur jean michel vous avez
de vous habitez ou maintenant hâte avant
à côté de fatma de touraine et de tours
a qu'à côté tour bosser voilà dans la
voirie tout ça toujours beau gosse
écrivent toujours envie légitime se lève
toujours tout va bien bah oui monsieur
roux
écrivez nous vous aimeriez pour l amour
est bon des fois oui des fois non ah ben
ça c'est le coup de main d'ouvre abbaoui
c'est pareil cauchemar que je gêne quand
il se doit est en couple à
sanaa oui j'aimerais bien mais bon ouais
je prends mon temps il paraît que vous
avez reçu des lettres de alors ça c'est
très marrant vous recevez du courrier
d'homosexuels genre suivi oui des fois
oui c'est vous avez aucun et il répond
pas nous intéresse pas non non vous
répondez pas maintenant je l avais
répondu
jean-michel
fait rire ça me fait rire habitants
veulent envoyer un courrier non c'est
pas dans une boîte si vous répondez vous
c'est si vous répondez quelque chose pas
du tout je réponds je réponds pas mais
après voilà j'envoie un message facebook
parce que j'ai une page officielle donc
je remercie ah oui là ils sont six
succès sur l'officiel et à trois
bouquins alors à côté justement deux
très beaux garçons c'était le projet
reçoit pas de dire qu'il est gay mais ça
me tient le premier couple gay de
l'amour est dans le pré voilà alors je
dois reconnaître que moi j'étais passé à
côté de vous à m'étonne cette histoire
naturelle etc santé has et parce que
cette saison 15 cette saison 15 parce
que ce que je remarque c'est que mathieu
respecte les gay marié pourquoi voilà ce
qu'il essayait pas de draguer c'est ce
que voit exactement
c'est un peu moi dans dix minutes je
suis tantôt les genoux
vu dans la
série
enfin j'aime à la crise tant qu'elle
apprend deviennent plus pour me
connaître
alors speed dating voilà ça s'est passé
pendant speed dating le coup de coude on
regarde masanobu de faux noms
[Musique]
ça va
oui
merde je suis même pas mais je désolé
alors enfin ouais c'est très bizarre
ouais ouais
il s'est posé les choses comme moi
je tremble
oui sanchez maire de
caracas des musées comme qui font penser
à l'amour
la toile
mcafee
c'est autant
ces récents parce que tu pèses way
jamais mangé j'aime bien le rosé moi j'y
vois pas tu vois pas non niveau pas là
ça va lui servir bien mec qui fait donc
mois par drogue non
drogue
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'on parle avant que tu te
mariage parce qu'à moi on va parler
aussi des conséquences de tout salarié
le mariage c'est tellement beau tu lis
cette lettre à l'ex est en train de rire
lamielle dans laquelle je demande en
mariage
[Musique]
on est en train de changer ma vie a
changé ma vie
mais ça tu le sais
ne pas mes tenues
d'abord ce sera le premier mariage
griffe démission
mais aussi le premier mariage gay en
camargue dans le monde m
son interview
[Musique]
w
oui ou non merde
[Musique]
c'est nouveau c'est le temps qu'il
aimait bien que vous ne vouliez pas d'un
écart d'âge aussi important alors bon je
vais pas d'un écart d'âge important je
vous ai déjà je veux pas m'emporter moi
je voulais un mètre 95 route king musclé
façon lui a monté sa chaise mais ils
ferment à 63 non non c'est petit creux
grise mais les minions voila voila mais
les super lashing s'étaient tous là vers
ce que je voulais ah oui comme quoi
l'amour n'a pas de rien mais bizarrement
quand même plus comme moi m 87 costaud
mais
on joue alors que j'étais plus jeune
donc voilà donc les cardiaques les toits
les cards asador j'ai pas du tout non au
contraire je pensais pas que vincent non
plus oui mais non la magasin 40 s'est
pas non plus 45 à 65 tu vas tu vas
bientôt l'être du temps la tabbee mois
temps ça et vous serez plus on sort la
semaine prochaine tu vois la ville
si non non non l'essayer que faisait mon
psy la vie c'est ici et maintenant
maintenant j'ai du monde et là il ya le
baiser on va leur vie parce que en jeu
comme lui avait un décompte eu lieu un
couple gay dans cette émission j'étais
un peu premier à dire la caricature
téléréalité machin quand je le vois
maintenant et quand on va parler aussi
de ce qui s'est passé derrière les
menaces de mort bah je regrette ce que
j'ai dit regardez il est vrai qu'en ce
qu'il dit issing j'ai complètement et me
déconnecter quoi tout est devenue floue
mais plutôt c'est vrai mais j'en avais
des frissons rien dit ce moment là je
sais mais c'est lui quoi
il faut que ça soit lui c'est obligé
[Musique]
alors en début de ce2 ont pâti outre et
sabots et bat tout le monde n'a pas
trouvé ça beau ouais alors est ce qu'il
faut c'est le premier baiser entre deux
hommes dans une télé réalité dans les
séries les films faciles vu mais dans
les séries films il ya toujours une
distance sur un plateau télé oui
j mais
je n'étais pas me ramasser la vie
d'alain
fabien
hecquet qu'est ce que c'est comme
conséquence pour vous ça à bas des
milliers de menaces de mort mais des
lendemains ses dirigeants une blague
s'est intégralement des lettres écrites
manuscrites au bas c'était sur les
abeilles a eu williams de courrier chez
nous et sinon sur le réseau bah oui je
messages ou des commentaires aussi
classiquement ça a été une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a déménagé aussi mais
non ici bas on est on est les seuls
agriculteurs des de l'amour est dans le
pré est jamais avoir donné un autre
adresse
et sur les maisons plus proches autour
de vous les voisins et tout ça c'est des
conséquences négatives ou pas non non
pas du tout prenons tout mais tu vois
par exemple gens sont bienveillants en
face à face est vrai effectivement oui
mais pour d'autres mariages le on a été
obligé d'être d'avoir la gendarmerie
ouais quatre vies plus de gendarmerie
pour escorter c'est fou hein sinon c'est
un dernier rebond n'est pas on a passé
cinq mois en cours en martinique pour
pour faire la tournée des classes et
charles et d'amour
la martiniquaise
on a adoré et et on a eu une menace de
mort terrible d'un conte fans
d'un chanteur on va pas rentrer dans les
détails on a dû reporté plein de faim
bravo m système c'est là qu'on voit
vraiment que c'est important des aides
alors il a doucement doucement vraiment
de quoi inciter ya de vrais évident
absolument d'autant que vous n'êtes pas
du tout caricaturaux je pense que le
jour où j'avais dit ça dans l'émission
tpm puis j'avais pas vu l'émission 1 ça
peut arriver parfois que je parle de
choses et je connais toi même s'il était
même si les efféminés ou peu importe
leur type ça n'aurait absolument rien
changé c'est pas que c'est qu'ils ont
l'air masculins qui ont le droit de
s'embrasser
et alors il visiterait que par dont il
est question a donc surpris quand vous
voulez vous aviez vous aviez une
pathologie sévère un truc qui peuvent
rouler dessus à tout moment c'est tout
et c'est toujours mais stabilisé alors
cela s'appelle la maladie de cas d'asile
c'est une maladie on est au moins 2000
en france à l'avoir sinde gérer ce
dégénérescence cérébrale j'ai 100 % de
chances d'en mourir
l'espérance de vie de 62 ans j'en ai
bientôt 47 donc tu vois un petit peu le
meilleur mais en tout cas
vous voulez avoir des enfants ouais et
est-ce que ça du coup c'est une question
parce que si vous avez si vous arrivez à
avoir des enfants ce qui prend déjà pas
mal de temps est ce que le fait que du
coup y ait cette cette échéance qui est
très négative et je suis désolé mais est
ce que ça vous fait poser des questions
parce que finalement si cet enfant
arrive un père vous allez vous retrouver
seul peut-être pour l'éduquer c'est pas
évident déjà que deux hommes c'est pas
facile à faire rentrer dans les dents
l'était déjà non mais c'est qu'il
y avait déjà pensé immédiatement il a
beaucoup de réfléchi et lui il se sent
très à déjà prendre en charge tout
l'accord et puis on va peut-être passer
au travers et puis surtout vous n'êtes
pas morts encore
non mais ça alors alors déborah et puis
je suis aussi clair ministre qui nous a
contactés oui tu les moyens quelque
chose qui m'avait beaucoup touché vous
avez dit que vous étiez déjà en train de
chercher un remplaçant
entre guillemets non non à votre alors
c'était pas qu on est en train de
chercher un remplaçant c'est à dire que
le jour où moi j'arrivais au terme
je me sentirais soulagés de le savoir
avec sa part qu'il est déjà
un bon mois
rethel jusqu'à 50 watts c'étaient les
loisirs c'est une interview télé loisirs
ils ont ressorti et ce matin on avait un
message d'un gars le jeune garçon qui
disait alors ils cherchent à quelques
points lexandre je suis preneur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas encore de garde vous parlez
de 2,22 qu'une mère très touchante juste
un petit mot près de faire cours le
ministre qu'est ce que vous avez dit de
la ministre et un jour elle était en
rénovation dans le gard a absolument
voulu nous voir sacha 2010 nous a
appelés et la femme extraordinaire et
elle à maryse et notre mission en
martinique elle va très bien eh ben
c'est très très bon ministre de
l'égalité des chances mais ça avance
doucement grâce à des gens comme vous tu
vois par exemple on vient de passer une
semaine à lille on a vu trois cent
cinquante élèves on a avec sos
homophobie on a parlé d'amour
d'inclusion
[Musique]